good afternoon and welcome to at yale
live i'm eric gershon the 2012 elections
are over and americans have returned the
sitting president to the white house the
balance of power in congress remains
little changed republicans keep control
of the house of representatives
democrats keep control of the senate
so how will america change what does the
near future of the united states look
like what are the issues we can expect
our leaders to address and how three
yale scholars join us today to offer
their thoughts on the election's likely
consequences for near-term public policy
jacob hacker political scientist and
director of yale's institution for
social and policy studies
beverly gage historian of the us
political ideology and institutions and
from the yale school of management david
bach who studies and teaches about
financial market regulation
and global business we are delighted to
have you all here thank you for having
us so let's let's jump right in
we've got the president back in the
white house we've got a congress it's
roughly balanced about the same how has
the environment for governance changed
well as you described it right it hasn't
changed in a fundamental way
the house republicans have lost a few of
their ranks but it's still a very
conservative caucus and so the real
question is how will republicans respond
to the election results
leading up to
the election the central issue
was this question of what we were going
to do to deal with the expiring bush tax
cuts and and a bunch of spending cuts
that are scheduled to go into effect and
now are being called the fiscal cliff
and that's going to be the the first
order of business of congress is dealing
with that in fact it'll be the lame duck
session it won't be the newly elected
members and if you look at the
statements that are coming out of the
white house and republi and the
republican caucus john boehner you know
i think it's right now there maybe is a
little bit of a sign toward conciliation
on the part of the house there's a bit
more of mojo on the part of the uh of
the president but it sounds like we're
we're back at you know the same
fundamental issue which has to do with
to what extent of revenues tax uh you
know letting these tax cuts expire be a
big part of the
of the package and
you know my my own view is that the the
democrats are probably going to have to
go
pretty far to push the republican caucus
um there isn't a real sign yet
that republicans read this election as
being a kind of repudiation of
more fundamental aspects of their
governing philosophy
there's a sense that they're at a
strategic disadvantage in this fight but
i still think it's going to be a really
fierce battle and we
are you know probably happy to forget
that the debt ceiling uh is actually an
issue um you know that right now um
everyone's focused on the fiscal cliff
but soon the debt ceiling will be
reached again and we'll have the same
fight the same kind of fight that we had
in 2011. so
so i think that's the way to understand
it what is going to be the strategic
response of republicans to the election
results because the basic uh balance of
power hasn't really changed so you said
the democrats are going to have to go
pretty far what do you mean by that well
i mean the way people are talking about
now is go over the cliff which makes it
sound like it's all going to happen on
one day
the big
the big aspect of the cliff that people
talk about is the expiring tax cuts
and so that will happen at the beginning
of the new year and there is a broad
sense among democrats particularly more
liberal democrats that to get the
republicans to sign on to serious
revenue increases which would mean
letting the bush tax cuts expire for the
richest two percent of americans for
income levels above 250 000 at least
substantially raising those rates maybe
not going back to the clinton era rates
for that to happen you're going to have
to go over the cliff you're going to
have to actually see the the tax
the tax increase
tax increases for that
for all americans go into effect that is
to have all the bush tax expired
including those for the middle class now
because the treasury department you know
because of tax day is until april 15th
and because you know there's with
there's withholding but you know the
treasury department has some latitude
there this may actually be more symbolic
than real and so the question is how
will the stock market respond how will
um you know how will the um you know the
uh commentators respond uh but
republicans feel as if that um they are
likely as in uh to take a
substantial share of the blame if this
happens and so democrats are thinking if
if they push over the cliff that they're
likely to be in a stronger bargaining
position i just mentioned one other
thing which i think is really
you know crucial to understand in this
debate and that is that
the republicans are not just worried
about democrats they're worried about
their own political base you know the
the biggest concern up till now has been
grover norquist and his anti-tax pledge
and norquist has made clear that while
you know you could
rejigger the tax code in ways that might
raise revenues without violating his no
new taxes pledge that
actually raising the top tax brackets
counts as a tax increase now some
republicans and democrats say well you
know if we go over the cliff then all of
a sudden all bets are off but you know
norquist is not a dumb guy right he
knows that that's that's what they you
know he knows that that counts as
allowing tax rates to go up for the top
um and so um does norquist have the kind
of sway he did before it didn't the
folks who signed the pledge the new the
new candidates who signed the pledge did
not do particularly well there's a sense
that you know there has to be some
serious adjustments in the budget and
that
the kind of dogmatic position that
norquist has isn't as viable as it used
to be but
um people have bet against this kind of
hard-line stance before and lost and um
republicans uh are pretty well protected
in the house you know they they've been
reelected at very high rates uh they
have well the money that was in the
election didn't seem to make a big
difference at the aggregate level it's
it did help uh shield uh republican
incumbents and so there may be a wise a
sense within the republican caucus they
can wait the storm out and that while
they'll have to accept some increase in
revenues and and much of it coming from
the wealthiest of americans so they
wouldn't have to go all the way so does
the president's re-election um improve
his negotiating position and with this
respect to this issue at all in the view
of any of you
well i'd say that that actually is one
place where things have changed so not
simply the fact that obama was
re-elected which obviously puts him
in a slightly different position in
terms of not needing to then run for
re-election one more time but i think
one of the big questions that was on the
table here was what kind of public
narrative we were going to have about
the obama presidency and that was one of
the things that was being decided here
you know when barack obama was
elected there was a lot of talk that we
were entering kind of a shift in the
ideological cycles of american politics
and in the kind of cycles of party
dominance in american politics which is
to say that roughly from uh franklin
roosevelt through to ronald reagan we
had a period that was roughly
characterized as being really dominated
by the democratic party dominated by
kind of liberal ideas with the rise of
ronald reagan and then through the bush
presidencies we had a period that's
really dominated by more conservative
ideas dominated by the republican party
structurally and one of the big
questions was so did the election of
barack obama signal some kind of
emerging shift both ideologically and in
terms of party coalitions and in terms
of who was going to be really uh pushing
and who was going to be reacting for the
future
and i think had he not been reelected we
would have seen a story emerge that
there was a moment of crisis
something weird happened which is that
we elected the first african-american
president we elected a democrat but you
know things went back to the way that
they were before and the fact that he's
been reelected i think really
fundamentally changes that narrative and
makes uh much bigger questions possible
now about uh the ways in which big ideas
are shifting uh it makes things possible
for obama himself
again not only the fact that he's not
going to have to run for reelection
but the fact that he has been kind of
affirmed in a different way he's not
just a president who kind of came to
power in a moment of crisis now right he
is someone whose policies and ideas have
been affirmed in what was uh certainly a
close election and i think in many ways
a much closer election than the public
narrative at the moment is actually
suggesting that it was certainly in
historical terms this was a very close
election and maybe that's something
that we want to talk about a little bit
but i do think he's gained the ability
to kind of capitalize on and create his
own narrative now um in ways that that
were less possible at earlier moments
and i would just say to follow on that
that i think that
there was a lot of criticism the
president really didn't have a very
ambitious forward-looking agenda
but that vice perhaps could be a virtue
when it comes to this issue because he
did talk a lot about how the one thing
he wasn't gonna let happen was to let uh
to let us go forward and extend tax cuts
for rich people who like him he keeps
saying people who don't need it so so in
that sense i think there are very few
mandates you can read and i'm generally
skeptical about reading mandates into
election results period but there's very
few mandates you can read into this
election i think um but this is one of
them right and the president clearly
thinks that he has the upper hand on
this you said exactly that yesterday at
the press conference that look i mean
the one thing that i've been saying
consistently is exactly that i think
you're right i mean it isn't just that
he was re-elected but it was also how he
was re-elected the fact that the
coalition held up that there was a
governing coalition that perhaps we
haven't seen in the past before about
minorities about
women about young people about urban
voters and you know if you look at the
demographics you look at the exit polls
a lot of these people agree that some of
the wealthiest need to pay more the
interesting thing of course with this
with cliff is and i think you're
absolutely right jacob about you know it
doesn't kick in right away well you know
on january 1st once we've gone over it
republicans and democrats can come
together and put in place a tax cut for
98 of americans that's a pretty popular
thing to do now grover norquist can say
well you know you raise them for two
percent well nobody raised anything that
decision was taken more than a year ago
it just now happens and then we all come
together to declare victory for you know
cutting taxes for 90 years that's a very
positive view but it does remind me that
back when the bush tax cuts were enacted
there was sort of democratic and liberal
wags who were saying that bush not only
passed the one of the largest tax cuts
in american history but also one of the
largest tax hikes and we should
because of course these were all set to
expire and they've been extended now in
two separate um periods and we should
remember that the reason that they were
not
put in place permanently um was because
of the the budget rules and they were
not willing to if if they'd been willing
to specify ways to pay for them
indefinitely then of course uh they
would be able to stay on the books so
you know this this has been a um
an ongoing issue for republicans it was
really playing to their advantage every
time this came up they said look we're
gonna have this massive tax increase you
know and and strategically it seemed as
if it was really working to their
advantage i think the uh you know
again
with a kind of modest targeted approach
the administration has put the
republicans actually a pretty difficult
strategic position they came in saying
oh you know we're going to let all of
these tax cuts continue except for this
small portion which turns out to be a
pretty big chunk of money but a small
share of the population the 800 billion
dollars over 10 years that goes to the
top two percent and you know with the
economy weak and with the president's
position frankly week after the 2010
midterms they weren't able to get it now
i think they feel pretty confident they
can get something uh substantial or
if not you know returning to the clinton
era tax rates for the top at least uh at
least having some movement in that
direction plus some kinds of tax reform
capping tax deductions that will raise
money as well
given uh the urgency and the deadline
for dealing with the fiscal cliff it's
taking up a lot of
space in uh the print media and the
broadcast media it's it's on everybody's
uh mind um well whatever is left over
from the portrayal scandal right
exactly right the fact that we're going
over the cliff that it's four percent of
gdp comes second this first time media
is concerned this is great because
they've been coming up with ways to
dramatize the fiscal cliff you know it's
like someone louise style you know
showing big pictures of cliffs and you
know the the the fear that we should all
be feeling about this but frankly their
heart's not really in it right it's a
policy issue you know most of the cable
news is just not interested in all of a
sudden sex scandal it's just that happy
days are here
just be thankful it's not the grover
norquist sex which would really really
take us over
so so one theme obviously um that we
heard a lot about in the campaign uh
certainly from uh mitt romney was about
jobs uh jobs and employment um and we've
got roughly eight percent national
unemployment uh still now and gdp is not
really growing all that fast so it seems
like
once the
panic
for lack of a better term over the
fiscal cliff subsides somewhat jobs are
likely to re-emerge as a front burner
issue and so i wonder if if any of you
have
thoughts on
you know actions meaningful actions that
government can take and that the
president to the extent that the
president can actually influence the
economy
should or could take
well i think the the good news for obama
is that in fact right things are
when we when we stand back in 30 years
and look at his presidency there's a
very very good likelihood that compared
to the moment that he came into office
the place that we're going to end up in
2016 is going to be much much better and
probably better than where we are now i
mean of course there are precedents like
for instance the 1937 election in which
franklin roosevelt was he the last
democrat to be re-elected with the
majority i believe there are people are
playing around with all of these uh all
of these uh kind of historical
comparisons at the moment but he's
elected in an overwhelming landslide
that uh we haven't seen the likes of in
a long long time in american politics
and of course immediately hits a new
recession and i don't think that there's
a lot of expectation about that though
that is of course one of the concerns as
we as we talk about the fiscal cliff
here but uh the likelihood is that in
terms of his presidency whatever he does
things are going to look better by the
time he's leaving office than they did
uh when he started i would only say
whatever he does within some pride right
could really screw it up and he and they
understand that i mean the the the
uh the fdr example is a good one because
in 38 there was a real belt tightening
that took place at roosevelt's
insistence and it turned out to you know
precipitate major reversal and um so the
the administration the president are
acutely aware that while they would like
to get some kind of bargain budget
bargaining shouldn't contract spending
substantially in the short term it
shouldn't impose um
a lot of it shouldn't be attract getting
a lot of new revenue particularly from
from the middle you know from middle and
lower income americans in the near term
uh and you know my my concern is that
this if we think about the jobs picture
is that you know the the we have seen
even before the downturn we saw a
relatively slow job growth we didn't see
big middle-income gains
i mean i completely agree with bev that
things are going to be a lot better in
four years than they were uh in 2008 and
i really hope and and expect they'll be
better than they are now but it seems to
me that probably more is going to be
needed in the short to medium term to
try to boost um job growth and it's not
clear that
there's a real
neither an appetite in washington or a
strategy on the part of the president to
get that done
and so
you know there is some mobilization in
the in the wake of the election to try
to bring that issue to the front and
center labor groups sort of the the
usual suspects have said look let's do
some serious infrastructure spending now
it seems to be the only thing you might
get business and labor to agree on um
you know i think that there are some
possible possibilities
but this is really an administration i
think sees it itself as having two main
priorities one is getting some kind of
deal here that leaves room open for some
public investment
and two consolidating on the
big legislative achievements of the
first four years so making sure the
affordable care act is implemented
making sure that the dodd-frank
financial reform uh legislation is
implemented so you know it may not it
you know it may be that the
administration has to hope that there's
that momentum inherent in the trajectory
of the economy because as far as i can
see it there isn't a real like strategy
for for for medium or longer term growth
that they're that's being talked about
right now and the debate in that respect
i mean the entire campaign has been
misleading right and you have basically
two guys fighting over who's better at
creating jobs okay none of them is good
at it you know that's actually not what
the government does i mean in that
respect you know
the critics are right i mean if romney
for all his you know rhetoric about you
know business and small business
whatever i create jobs i'm going to
create 20 million jobs it's about
setting the conditions and actually i
think that's exactly right you're right
also i mean a lot of the uh you know
difficult decisions have have been made
and job growth is is slow and you know
you've done some great work about some
of the structural reasons why
potentially the recovery you know favors
some more than others but from a
cyclical perspective you know things are
improving and and really you know going
back to your point is about not messing
it up now one way of messing it up is
actually not getting a deal done in the
short term right i mean it is you know
up to four percent of gdp that we're
talking about there's a couple of other
things that will be important
in terms of energy costs for example i
think that's an area where i think if an
effort can be made to make sure energy
costs remain relatively low uh that's
been uh you know supporting a sort of
renaissance of manufacturing and part of
the us that's going to be important so
certainly things that can be done
some people are talking about a you know
an additional package i agree i think
that's that's you know relatively
relatively unlikely even though a lot of
economists are saying what we need is
actually still some stimulus in the
short term with a very credible
commitment about consolidation in the
medium to long term the problem is you
know politics don't work that way it's
incredibly difficult to make that kind
of a medium to long term commitment
credible as far as financial markets are
concerned so you remember at some point
in the campaign
there was a lot of attention focused on
the fact that no incumbent president had
been re-elected with unemployment um as
high as it was at the time barack obama
was re-elected despite that so does it
does that suggest to you that the
electorate really wasn't uh persuaded
that
you know despite everything that both
candidates were saying that they were
going to be able to make a big
difference in the jobs picture well i
think that was part of it but i put my
political science hat on for just a
moment and say that you know that meme
that you know that the unemployment rate
or even the growth of gdp is sort of the
most important determinant of the
prospects for a president is just at
odds with most of the research that
suggests that
um
that
there is a wide
wide range of outcomes possible at an
unemployment rate of around
seven to eight percent um so the
president was at the upper end of the
the level where you would expect that he
could get reelected but he had
incumbency advantage in his favor um he
had the direction of the economy in his
favor there's you know there's uh mixed
but i think pretty pretty good evidence
that it's really the period just prior
to the election that's crucial and i
think that um
then finally so those two things matter
a lot then finally i would say that um
that the the campaigns um and the sort
of choice that's presented the
electorate does matter and you know what
was really striking to me here was the
extent was just how
you know despite all the talk about
undecided voters and shifts in the final
you know months was just how stable the
divide was and how much it came down to
the president and his really impressive
campaign team getting out people um to
vote and um and probably and this this
we'll see how long lived this is it did
rest on a bit of a structural advantage
the democrats seem to enjoy right now
you know we've historically talked about
how the republicans might enjoy a
structural advantage in the electoral
college because um democrats kind of uh
yeah waste a lot of votes in urban areas
and and and
some of the sparsely some of the densely
populated um democratic states but this
time around um you know there are
estimates that the democrats the
republicans would have had to have a two
percentage point national vote advantage
to win the electoral college which is
you know pretty remarkable so had there
could have there were scenarios under
which the the
president obama would lose the popular
vote and win the electoral college with
a pretty good margin and so
that suggests that it maybe we're seeing
with the consolidation of a very
strongly republican electorate on one
side and democrat electric on the other
side and the matching of it up with some
of these states that have um you know
that are very you know that are very um
solid very very solidly republican that
they're the republicans actually at the
national level at the electoral college
level maybe have a little bit of a
disadvantage but my view is coming back
to it that the economy
was
good enough that people that incumbency
advantage and the choice element of the
election could become much more
important and with regard to the latter
i would just say with regard to the
choice that you know the republicans you
know romney kind of moved back to the
center right before the election but the
republicans basically
doubled down on a pretty conservative
economic position and
coupled with a an electorate that's
changing it just didn't resonate it just
didn't resonate you know obama did not
have it you know he pushed back hard
against that he was very hard on you
know he tried to shoot up the
unfavorability ratings of romney but he
did he he did not have i would say some
kind of like wham bam with g whiz kind
of economic message out there it was
just that he was he was very clearly
pushing back against what would be
considered the more kind of uh
conservative economic elements of the
republican agenda and those elements did
not do a very good job of getting people
who were not already hardcore republican
supporters and and the exit polls
reflect that also right i mean i think
you know for for me one of the main
moments of the campaign was bill
clinton's speech when he said you know
basically the message that they're
probably concerned you know we messed it
up he hasn't fixed it in four years it's
time to put us back in
and i think the obama team actually then
ran with that i mean it provided a
narrative for what they've been saying
before
and if you look at the exit polls you
know more people still faulted the bush
administration and their economic policy
for the current crisis than the obama
administration and and that's something
that i think is lost if you just look at
the macroeconomic numbers or the labor
market numbers right because there are
some elections in which it really
doesn't matter who the candidates are
right it's very clear it doesn't really
matter who the candidates are and it
doesn't really matter how well the
campaign campaigns are done right
they're just going to go one way or
another and this absolutely was not one
of those campaigns right i mean this was
a situation in which despite structural
advantages that are really pretty small
if they exist at all
you know it was it was definitely an
election to be won or to be lost um mitt
romney was not in the end i think a very
good candidate and one of the questions
is does then the analysis on the
republican side uh come out and
emphasize the fact that mitt romney
himself was just not a great candidate
right the way we think about bob dole i
mean bob dole wasn't going to win his
election anyway but i think people say
okay well he wasn't you know he wasn't a
great candidate but there wasn't some
sort of fundamental rethinking and sea
change in in the kinds of ideas that
might be driving that
and i think the question is even if we
accept that mitt romney was
not the world's greatest candidate do we
nonetheless need to rethink more
fundamental things or is that going to
be where the analysis ends and i think
we don't really have a clear picture and
there's a real debate going on in the
republican party around
that very question i will note that mitt
romney's phone call uh recently in which
he i think it was yesterday in which he
said that you know the reason that he
had lost was that obama had been handing
out you know government favors to all of
the people who voted for him gifts gifts
exactly uh was quite astonishing and and
my response to that was wow i can't
believe you really were just such a bad
candidate that's just not going to get
you uh get you very far i mean there is
some truth in i think the insight that
in fact often the way that people relate
to
government and shape their ideas about
government are is in fact by their
tangible relationship with government
right so in fact if it turns out that
the government helped you when you
really needed a loan and you were able
to go to college as a result yes that
does in fact
to provide benefits to people whom they
hope will vote for them
right exactly this is taking place in
washington but um but i actually think
that that
i i think there should be some serious
tool searching because um it's true that
romney had deficiencies as a candidate
but i didn't see anyone
in certainly who decided to actually run
right who was a stronger general
election candidate than him and if you
will remember just before the election
when
either sincerely or strategically
republicans are expressing the belief
that they were going to win this
election
there were not a lot of questions and
there was actually i mean i would say
the most remarkable thing to me was that
republicans just prior to the election
were willing to to support romney as he
moved pretty dramatically toward the
center um with you know and i you know i
saw it as basically a a a very uh a
savvy recognition that the you know
winning losing a losing candidate cannot
do anything and so if if romney has to
moderate its positions in some areas if
that's what it takes to win let's
support him in doing that but suddenly
after election a lot of hardcore
conservatives have suddenly said that
you know romney is the michael dukakis
of the republican party and that's just
that's just not true except for the fact
they were both massachusetts governors
um no it was he was a he was a candidate
with flaws but his favorability ratings
on the eve of the election were actually
not as bad as people think they were you
know up there and relatively close to
the president um
he made some really big missteps which
seemed completely sincerely to express
like like you know the the old saying
that that that a gaff is when a
candidate says the politician says what
he really believes the 47
um statement i think was a really big
deal a really big misstep because it
expressed what um what core parts the
republican party thought about um the
relationship between government and um
certain parts of the population and so
that to me
he was it was not the it was not the
messenger
it was a message if it was anything
about the campaign it was really the
weakness of the the republican get out
the vote operation compared with the
democrats what you said i mean in a way
the big obama gap right was the denver
debate performance and it was the same
thing i mean it seemed to confirm what a
lot of people feared that he wasn't
perhaps as passionate about the job
anymore as he was that he was
disillusioned that he actually didn't
really have a plan and there he shows up
and it gives you the feeling he doesn't
want to be there so you know almost did
him in despite you know many of the
things to pull down that's right that's
right let me bring up healthcare because
that was something that might have
changed significantly in a different
direction if mitt romney had been
elected president right i mean that was
one of his day one activities was
repealing the president's health care
plan um do you think you would have done
that
well i think the first i mean i think he
there would have been
some major
changes in the law um what repeal and
replace meant sort of morphed over the
course of the campaign romney at one
point said my plan includes a uh
protection for people with pre-existing
traditions you know one of his campaign
uh uh uh staff later had to go to the
reporters and said well you know when he
said that it's not really true it's if
you were if you were
you know i haven't thought through
exactly what the the revised their
visions would be but let's be clear that
the
um
that this was a close election as bev
was saying and a lot in policy terms
hung on it and the reason is that
because even though it's hard to get
things done in washington um the big
challenge is getting would have been
getting over a democratic filibuster so
let's say everything was the same but
romney won it probably they would have
done a little better in the senate had
romney won and and the house but um but
so they have a house majority they might
have a slightly uh um
uh close they might be slightly closer
to a senate majority romney would have
immediately gone to the reconciliation
process the budget process he would have
he would have through that process
probably extended
all the bush tax cuts
you know there was debate about exactly
what his tax package would look like but
i think the immediate goal would have
been to try to lock in those and then he
would have probably tried to strip out
most of the subsidies in the health care
law some of the other requirements the
reconciliation process the budget
process as we learned during the health
care fight doesn't allow you to do
anything you want there's rules about
what's germaine but you can do almost
anything that involves taxes and public
programs and financing and so core
elements the health care law the
medicaid expansion the subsidies for
coverage i think would have been in deep
jeopardy and so we
you know i think this really is a
reminder of how consequential elections
can be for policy and and i want to be
clear that i don't think that for most
people they understood that these issues
hung into balance i mean there's been
some warming to the health care law
among the public but honestly what we
find is that these fights which hinge on
get out the vote operations and sort of
gauzy things about the candidates as a
whole maybe one or two big issues
determine in a very polarized
environment a whole host of issues that
depend on control of the levels of
government in a in a political world in
which uh honestly it's so hard to get
things done that once you get something
in place it protecting it is really uh
you're an advantaged position so so what
is left what is the heavy lifting left
for the obama administration with
respect to health the the health care
bill well it's really rather it's really
getting the states to act um so there
are two things one is that the supreme
court decision last year said that the
medicaid expansion which is a big part
of how coverage will be expanded under
the law was optional for the states
so
the states
the the the administration was arguing
that all of medicaid funding should be
contingent on whether they did this
expansion the expansion is in depending
on where states are it's up is from
where they are up to about 140 percent
of the poverty level and
now the states have the option of of not
going ahead but the fact is is that the
initial federal share of that um
expansion is like a hundred percent and
then it declines a bit over time so it's
basically free money to the states to
expand medicaid i'd be surprised you
know states would really have to be you
know their leadership would have to
really be ideologically committed to not
expanding medicaid to give up that
opportunity
with regard to the health insurance
exchanges which is the other major way
that the law expands coverage
only a handful of states i think 11 at
last count have indicated they're going
to move ahead and create their own
exchanges some other states have said we
know we're not going to do it and some
have said we know we're going to do it
in partnership with the federal
government we're on the eve of the
state's determination of that if the
states do not
if they do not move ahead on their own
or they do not indicate to the federal
government they're going to create their
own exchanges the federal government
will create these exchanges these
marketplaces online marketplaces for
health insurance within those states
that's going to be the big challenge and
i get the sense just listening to the
rhetoric that a
a fair number of state leaders even
though they were hoping and holding out
until after the supreme court and then
after the romney yeah um
aren't really sure how to do it or what
to do and that's sort of troubling
and i think that a lot of states will
end up having the federal government
step in then the question becomes well
how eagerly and aggressively and
effectively will the federal government
set up these exchanges i mean the
argument for having the states do it
well the real argument was that you
couldn't get the senate to
60 members of the senate to agree um
without it but the real argument for
having the states do it is that they
have local knowledge and they have the
capacities there it's not an er you know
a decision that can't be revisited but
so we're going to see it's it's going to
be a messy scramble and we're going to
see a similar kind of mess around the
dodd-frank law and its implementation
which is not to say this is what
governance is like it's not to say that
these are disasters or or failures it's
to say that
you know law is not self-executing and
the administration is going to spend a
lot of time and it's allie's going to
spend a lot of time next year fighting
over achieving things that you know it
had already quote unquote won absolutely
and i would also add that to the degree
that we were i mean we're saying this in
the context of romney's recent comment
about people's relationship to
government and when government helps you
you vote for the people who might have
helped you i mean one of the things that
i think politically has been so
difficult about this law is that it was
passed it was big it was controversial
and then no one experienced it right and
so obama has been saying all along you
know try it and you'll like it exactly
and so now that's actually what's going
to happen and a lot of it is going to
its political consequences i think from
here on out you know jacob is absolutely
right that it's going to depend on
implementation and it's going to depend
you know its popularity as a law and a
set of programs is going to depend on
you know how it is that people actually
uh now experience it on the ground which
they really haven't been doing up to
this point and the exact same thing of
course is happening in parallel with the
other big achievement that you talked
about from the first term that is sort
of unfinished which is dodd-frank the
wall street reform act i mean it's it's
about i don't know what the final count
was 950 pages you compare that we've
been talking about ftr right every
single one that's right it's been
actually called the uh consultants and
lawyers full employment act of 2000 but
the i mean jokes aside i mean the
securities and exchange act was about 25
or 30 pages you know glass-steagall
wasn't very long you know this is a
massive bill and it's been criticized
for being relatively vague you now have
you know dozens of agencies some of them
who are already in existence others who
have been created you know issuing
thousands and thousands of pages of
regulation they have to find their way
to the financial system so you know
the policy is you're saying you know
it's complicated it's messy it takes
time but it does in the end affect
people's lives and they'll see it you
know when they when they get their
mortgage or refinance and so on so
there's going to be a lot of attention
now on the implementation of those two
you know major achievements so what new
issues do we think that the
administration itself is likely to push
hard on in the second term and beverly
actually i'm curious to hear a little
bit about um how presidents use their
second terms uh differently from the way
they use their first terms when they are
thinking very much about reelection
right right well i think it's it's an
open question about um
the obama administration because i think
they haven't been signaling very
strongly and aside from the things that
we've already already talked about right
i mean a lot of the election which is
fairly typical this round has been about
things that won't happen right if i
become uh president once again so uh
around things like the what the
republicans might do around abortion um
around kind of culturally conservative
issues right i'm gonna hold the line on
this and so is the is that action or or
inaction i think we've seen some signals
there i mean he's been talking a little
bit about immigration reform um and that
will be certainly one of the places
where seeing what the republicans are
doing see seeing kind of how bipartisan
that that becomes will be very
interesting but i think the truth is
that we that we actually don't know we
haven't seen a very kind of bold agenda
aside from the kinds of things that
we've been talking about um in terms of
what it is that presidents uh often do
right there are precedents for um
particularly democratic presidents uh
coming in with much larger much more
expansive agendas now that can go a
number of ways i mean lyndon johnson
wasn't really quite being re-elected in
the sense that um he hadn't actually
been elected for that first term after
kennedy was killed but
um you know sir he came back and off
with the war on poverty the great
society with this very broad ideological
vision which made a lot of changes
produced a lot of backlash i mean
franklin roosevelt when he came in in
1937 this is the story of
overreach of all overreaches right he
attempts to pack the supreme court
and he runs into real stonewalling but i
don't think in this case we're going to
see that kind of story i mean hey i
don't think obama's in any danger of
overreach if anything he's kind of in
danger of underreach and has long been
in danger of underreach uh in many ways
but in roosevelt's case you know what
actually happened in his second term was
that um his opposition really coalesced
and began to to stonewall in new ways
and that doesn't seem to be kind of the
direction that things are heading here
though though again we'll see so i think
it is actually one of the great open
questions um we're going to see some
consolidation of what's already happened
uh we're going to see some not doing
things that might happen under a
republican administration but i mean i
don't think we've seen
now we're moving on to legislative
triumph x y and z it just hasn't been
that i think immigration is the one area
where i would expect you know pretty
bold initiative and i think it's it's an
area will be you know very difficult at
least for some parts of the republican
party not to move after what just
happened in terms of the coalition the
other one i put out there and i'm i'm
you know
curious what your sense is you know very
mixed signals about the sort of
intersection of energy and
sustainability right
so it was a big deal when obama
campaigned in 2008 climate change
renewable energy uh energy independence
you know we got this we get this this
natural gas boom all of a sudden uh and
some politics around nicole all of a
sudden
the debate has shifted and it is about
energy independence but the climate
change part was entirely absent i mean
obama actually managed to spend i think
seven minutes talking in one of the
debates about
energy without ever mentioning climate
change then he mentions it in his
victory speech and yesterday he
downplayed it again in the press
conference so
you know that's an area where i think
there there is room for some bolder
initiatives but it's not clear exactly
in what direction he might want to go
let me interrupt for a second because
we've got a question from to take a
question from a viewer
and this is going to take us back to
electioneering and electoral politics
jared gilbert tweets us
to ask um
uh to note that that appeals to white
evangelicals seem to have lost some of
their potency um in the in the electoral
process how will um
political relationship to faiths evolve
in the next few years
do we think that religion is going to be
mitt romney's mormonism was not a big
issue as was once thought to be
is it going to be an issue in the future
religion oh it will certainly be an
issue i mean
it doesn't
yeah this is not disappearing from
american politics i mean the so
evangelical protestants uh except uh
yeah white evangelical protestants very
strongly supported the republican party
this was not a case of a weakening of
support or even really of
of weakened turnout it was of a much
better turnout operation on the other
side and there is certainly a story to
be told about younger voters they're
more likely to be secular even when they
have faith they're less likely to be
committed to
more conservative elements of
protestant
christian conservatism but but i think
there are two stories to tell here that
are just worth mentioning one is that
that so that that um alliance of the
kind of conservative economic philosophy
of the republican party and
christian conservatism has been has been
fraying for a while in the sense that
it's just not capable of producing
large enough electoral majorities if
you're getting substantial turnout uh
across the population um it's also
fraying it also was fraying i think
because the um the kind of conservative
economic message came at least up to
this last electoral cycle was coming to
dominate the tea party actually has a
lot of christian conservatives in it and
and interestingly that it really was
dominated by commitment to sort of
constitutional fidelity which some
people sort of see as a having a
biblical element to it and
conservative economic
theory but
this time around what was i think pretty
clear is that when the republican
candidates romney probably was the least
you know was the least committed to this
of of uh of some of the the major
leaders of the republican party who were
in the spotlight it was the senate
candidates really that brought this to
the fore um when they tried to sort of
go overtly appeal to the conservative um
religious base of the party they ran
into serious serious difficulties so my
sense is that this that this is still
going to be a core element of the party
if you look at the platforms it's the
republicans are very committed to
conservative
social issue positions but that it is
it is clearly not a winning electoral
strategy and in that respect there is a
shift
so it's not a shift in terms of the
ability of republicans or even the
eagerness of republicans to appeal to
conservative evangelical voters but of
the degree to which that allows them uh
to engineer electoral victories and so
the question is
where do do they they clearly and they
clearly are alienating some
uh you know non-trivial share of the
electorate with these appeals so the
question is do as before bev was asking
this more about the general philosophy
the republicans do they do they take
this as a sign that there's a need for
moderation or is it going are we going
to see this continuing um sort of uh
tension between midterm and and and
presidential elections where with the
lower turnout of midterms you can
actually use these strategies but it
becomes the achilles heel in the
presidential election i don't know but
to me it's uh
it's it's it's very it's a sort of
explosive side of republican politics
because it's both essential that they
continue to activate this core part of
the electorate and it's costly for their
long-term electoral success
let's turn to foreign policy there's a
lot going on in the world outside the
united states obviously
much of which the u.s is involved in
we've still got a lot of troops in
afghanistan uh china and the middle east
um uh offer something new and
interesting every day so um i wonder uh
what
um you think
the the the most immediate and can i
toss something in there because we're
again sort of narrowing the front yeah
so we're talking about a fiscal cliff
the entire european union is going over
a fiscal cliff right now it is the
biggest economic zone in the world you
know and it was entirely absent from the
debate the us plays an incredibly
important role at the imf um you know
even the foreign policy debate has been
focusing narrowly on a couple of places
you know we we can start with those
places but let's also you know remember
the rest of the world that is looking to
us leadership and a whole range of
issues well keep going well you know
well the greek economy contracted seven
percent yesterday annually right i mean
this is you know you're seeing the
disintegration of you know a project
that has been going on over two
generations really with u.s support but
i think more importantly it raises some
important questions again about the
sustainability of our model of balancing
um you know market economies with you
know somewhat comprehensive social
protections um and
you know it raises questions about the
role of financial markets and all of
this and how they get regulated the us
and the european union have come up with
somewhat different responses to you know
the the 2008-2009 financial crisis so
you know the major challenges um that
not just affect the future of the global
economy but also some of the other
debates about how we work our way back
out of this
financial crisis and they were entirely
missing from the campaign i actually
think you know you were talking you were
asking beth before about how second
terms are different from first terms you
think about reagan you think about
clinton it's much more about foreign
policy than the first term was you know
bush
two in that respect was probably a
little bit different because of of 9 11
primarily but
i would hope that we'll see a lot of
room for the president to actually lead
in international uh issues which include
of course the middle east
well in just a second though right i
think also the way in which europe has
been talked about in american politics
up to this point really has been on the
business pages right and the idea that
somehow the european crisis is going to
engulf the united states or what is the
united states going to do about it but
it and romney's conclusion we don't want
to be spain right i mean that was sort
of how it came into the debate
you're seeing really i mean look at what
happened in so many countries this week
right you're seeing actually this
growing level of social instability
social and political instability in
europe uh which hasn't really kind of
made its way on onto the american agenda
at all but seems to be on the increase
and um that maybe it's time for all of
this to get off the bus
and as a result of the implementation of
austerity policies that you know
you know you're talking about uh some of
the people who've been shaping
republican economic policy you know
that's part of what they've been
advocating to a certain extent right i
mean so there's a general debate
austerity um how to manage your debt how
to actually remain competitive without
um
getting rid of social protections you
know we're going to have a big debate in
the u.s probably
this period about entitlement reforms
and we've focused on the tax cuts and
and revenues you know republicans are
going to look for uh some concessions
when it comes to entitlements and so
those are some of the same issues that
that uh that you see playing out in
europe right now for example david what
are what are some steps that um the
united states could
government could realistically take to
have a meaningful influence on
circumstances talk some sense into
angela merkel
at this point i'm quite serious i mean
you know the i think
you know the us the chancellor of
germany yeah sure right so that's right
um so uh you know really i mean the the
um
you know the us actually despite you
know a lot of the rhetoric about
austerity you know there's actually been
quite a bit you know more fiscal
expansiveness than than what germany has
imposed on much of the southern european
countries of course there is a big moral
hazard problem and you know that is
actually what is going on but you know
that perspective from the outside that
the european union is is you know
playing with fire that germany's
insistence on austerity is putting the
entire common currency at risk and that
is a a global issue and not just a an
intra-european issue i think is
important and you know obama by playing
with fire you mean the euro yeah i mean
the euro i mean well actually i mean the
euro from an economic perspective i the
euro is inseparable from the european
political project uh but then of course
also you know who else sort of
you know it espouses this this model of
of liberal economic policy you know
general uh emphasis on on a market
system but balancing it to a certain
extent with some social protection in
that respect you know europe has been uh
not too different from the u.s compared
to some of the other models that are now
uh flourishing in some emerging markets
right and and there is a a a a crisis of
the legitimacy of that particular model
that that i think you know is is not all
too different from what will be
discussed in the us potentially and i
would say just to add to that is that
you know there is that great old
benjamin franklin quote that if we don't
hang together we're going to hang
separately and i do think that what
we're seeing in the world economy right
now is you know the u.s has done
relatively better um and it's done
relatively better in part because it did
not pursue austerity policies the
perfect example of this comparison is
looking at britain and the united states
because their economic crisis was
relatively similar they have similar
economies in many respects and britain's
economy is you know much much more
liberal than other parts of europe in
the classical conservative sense but the
cameron government pursued an austerity
policy that actually hasn't fully kicked
in yet
and it just recently slipped back into
recession its budget deficit has gone up
and it's given the labor party actually
a real chance of recapturing the
government and
if you look across countries us has done
about as well as as almost any country
and that's partly because of the much
maligned stimulus package but looking
forward and this is really i think
there's a keynesian kind of dealing with
the financial cri you know okay there's
a financial crisis there's dealing with
a financial crisis uh and a keynesian
response that um and how and how
aggressively it was pursued but then
there's just this question of you know
what is the long-term growth trajectory
of advanced industrial democracies of
rich societies right what's the future
of the middle class the middle class is
the key in a world economy both places
and we're and we're we are hanging
together on that question
for better or worse um and um
and so if the euro you know i think this
is the sense in which the there's far
more similarity between the european
model and the american model than there
is between say the us model and the
chinese model and um and so really
thinking through how do you combine
um a basic level of economic security
investment in public goods and and um
and innovation with um you know with
competitiveness with um
rising uh living standards how do you
deal with the rising inequality in the
united states which you know the us is
leading the world uh in this dimension
the rich world in this dimension but
other countries are following us um and
that those kind of questions were
definitely not at the center of the of
the presidential debate although i think
inequality really was a kind of beneath
the surface one of the fundamental
issues but they are the center of the
question of what our society is going to
look like a generation or two from now
so
let me press you guys a little bit
on on afghanistan just because it seemed
to have been largely absent from uh as a
major campaign issue um
but if i'm not mistaken something like
68 000 troops still there
it's not on the front pages of
newspapers
very often lately
is uh do you think that the president do
you sense that the president has a real
commitment to um
to
continuing to wind down there and sort
of how good a job does the united states
appear to be doing in
helping
the afghans
create a government that that can manage
its own country
look at we should be in a very different
position at this point i mean i you know
i don't know if that's politically
correct to say i mean we're we're sort
of
trying to do or the us is trying to do
and and its allies at nato as as best as
they can but the mere fact that
you know 11 years after the beginning of
this you know we're still talking about
taliban strongholds we're still you know
concerned about
uh
whether the government there can sustain
itself you know really does highlight
that
we're not trying to
reach the lofty goal that was set out
here this is about
a reasonably responsible
draw down and withdrawal
not completely unlike what happened in
in iraq
the situation is going to be different
from the way it was before the invasion
but it's it's a it's a you know
far cry from what the original
goal was about what these countries you
know should be looking like nobody's
even talking about sort of solid
democratic representative institution
there it's really about putting the
government in a position where they can
provide some basic security and they can
continue the struggle against
extremism so
um
you know i think the administration
can't back down from their uh withdrawal
plans uh you know that would uh
be untenable and and it's just about you
know managing that withdrawal in the
most responsible way but
you know afghanistan
is
facing tremendous challenges just like
many other countries and that are
affected by extremism and and really i
think the west hasn't come up with
you know a sensible solution
for those challenges for those countries
sort of tried it our way made it a
little bit better didn't really succeed
in every respect back to you and i do so
and i was just going to say and i do
think you see
a real retreat on the part of the obama
administration i mean a real appetite in
the country not to be putting troops
anywhere right
having failed to some degree right i
mean having really not accomplished what
was uh supposed to be accomplished if it
was ever accomplishable which i don't
necessarily
agree that it ever was
possible from the beginning but
nonetheless you also see i think a very
disturbing turn and one that uh you know
when it came up in the debates
all you got was sort of agreement
between the two parties and this is one
of the reasons that uh foreign policy
didn't play such a big role in the
debates because it really wasn't a point
of very significant division between the
two candidates but it turned to
much more secretive intelligence-based
strategies the widespread use of drones
and these sorts of things that are going
on
really in increasing numbers
by our our uh our constitutional scholar
president
and i think ultimately these are going
to be one of the great legacies of the
obama administration but but really
aren't on the front page yet in ways
that uh you know they they may
ultimately be but
in ways that i think deserve more
attention
we've got just about five minutes left i
want to uh return uh to
a question about domestic politics this
is about the electoral college
uh so
you know we talked earlier in the in the
discussion about the fact that this was
a close election certainly in the
popular vote um the electoral college
was not close uh it was it was i don't
know if it's fair to call it a blowout
or not you tell me but it was a decisive
victory for the president in in the
electoral college um like it don't like
it will it ever change
all right well those are those are
different questions okay right hate it
um
on a scale of wonder yeah oh i don't
know but i mean you know
so here
let's count the things that are wrong
with the electoral college one is it's
malaportion i mean it's not as badly
malaportioned as the senate but it
reflects senate male apportionment so
you get the number of electoral college
votes as you have
some of districts and senate uh seats
and so that gives
these very sparsely populated states a
little extra
edge but that's
that's not the biggest aspect of it i
think the the other uh
other big thing is the so that i that i
supremely dislike about it is the
concentration of all
electioneering in the battleground
states um the fact that um that you get
this winner take all dynamic which means
you know that you really your goal is
really to try to get just as the
president did just over the the 50
threshold and everything else is
basically wasted and then i would just
say um
there is a real issue of legitimacy in
those cases and they do occur when the
electoral college vote and the popular
vote go different directions i was
secretly wishing just sort of in the
back of my mind but i'm not sure i i
think it would have been a bad outcome
on multiple dimensions that that
republicans have won the popular vote
and lost the electoral college vote only
because perhaps just perhaps you might
get
a little bit more interest in electoral
college reform i don't see it so you the
first question is do i like it no the
second is do i see a much of a prospect
of changing it no if 2000 didn't create
enough pressure to do it then i'm
doubtful that um there's anything
foreseeable that will i think the best
hope is that you that you move for a
variety of ways you move towards the
allocation of electoral college votes by
the states uh proportional to the vote
totals within those states it could only
be done i mean well
amar at the law school has three ways it
could be done but i only foresee it
being done basically through some kind
of multi-state compact and that's the
best we could hope for and that would be
pretty good
i agree not a fan not a fan don't like
the electoral college but uh just to add
one reason to to jacob's reasons it's
not just that it means presidential
candidates say don't come campaign in a
state like connecticut it actually
really missed that really right i mean
that might be a fine thing um but it
really profoundly affects the way that
people behave politically right so not
just that you have to go to a swing
state to do anything meaningful but the
ways in which it suppresses right
anyone's ability to sort of be activist
oriented in their hometown uh to make
political connections with their
neighbors to have it really matter
whether obama won connecticut by three
million vote i don't know how many
people quite live in connecticut we'll
we'll make our lowers a million votes uh
or or a hundred thousand votes if that
mattered that would actually be
transformative and not just at the level
of where television ads are being placed
but at the level of how people um behave
politically but i agree it's uh uh
nobody has enough of a concerted
interest in
better democracy right i mean nobody i
think at this point sees a very clear
partisan interest in changing that um
and outside of that it's often hard to
make really big changes david no i
completely agree i mean you know it does
doesn't make it fun for political
junkies to think about campaigns and you
start talking about all this but you
know i don't think it's going to change
i mean people of course will say that
one of the benefits is that states that
wouldn't get a lot of attention like you
know the iowas in new hampshire and so
on get a lot of attention but yes i mean
from an equity perspective you know why
should they get more attention in
california and new york or texas right
so
um you know as from a foreign
perspective you look at this you're like
oh my god you know this this system
makes no sense but i think when it was
built i mean it was built in late 18th
century it's it's
it's worked pretty well i mean in in the
sense of providing you know stable
democratic government um over a very
very long period of time and you know so
we'll probably be
you know with us way way past you know
our lifetime would be my guess
and if i can have one quick thing this
was a close election so our fact that we
say well was it a was it was it a
blowout right this sort of two little
more than two percent in the popular the
popular vote a little over about 130
votes in the electoral college that is
still closer even in the electoral
college than all but five elections in
the entire course of the 20th century
between 1900 to 1999 and the fact that
we actually understand this election to
have been so decisive and to have been a
blowout sort of indicates what a a sort
of strange historical period we're
actually living through where we've
become so used to close elections that
man you know as long as the electoral
college vote the popular vote match up
we're good to go and it's decisive yeah
well thank you very much for joining us
david beverly and jacob i hope you'll
come back and join us again sometime
and thanks to all of you for watching at
yale live we'll see you next time
you